President Trump will not be attending
this year's White House Correspondents
Dinner because he's taking his ball and
going home it treated this weekend
please wish everyone well and have a
great evening which is literally the
nicest thing he's ever tweeted our side
or said the playful annual banquet of
politicians journalists and entertainers
has been around since before the days of
president warren g harding and vice
president nate dogg calhoun here they
are in a file photo about to regulate
Wall Street Trump's decision is unusual
but other presidents have skipped the
event from the past JFK in 1962 to
protest the exclusion of women from the
press corps Reagan in 1981 following an
assassination attempt and bush in 2003
cos he locked himself in the Lincoln
bathroom and trying to get that door
comedian jokes made a habit of
disregarding presidential traditions
what's he going to flout next flick I
think this time Trump is going to defy
tradition by not lasting the whole fall
year in office
so he's not gonna pardon two turkeys
he's going to eat you turkeys alive just
man I think he's going to change the
lyrics of America the Beautiful to
America
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way a good friend Anthony
examiner who performed this incredible
Trump impression on our show on
countless occasions has volunteered to
attend and POTUS instead a lot of people
support the idea including Marc freaking
Hamel so let's make this happen
tweet at WHCA use the hashtag make
Anthony Trump again let's see if we can
[Applause]